inside Jessica Simpson's at st. Bart's  birthday getaway CT has the exclusive  pics from Jessica's Island Adventure it  all kicked off July 6th one just landed  on the breezy island with her husband  Eric Johnson her mom Tina and a few  close pals they spent the next week  relaxing all over the island but spent a  lot of time at their hotel the lay  Serenno villas on Jessica's actual bday  July 10th they threw a pool party  kicking back in the water with some  drinks lounging around on their deck and  even goofing off a bit there's Eric  wearing a headdress which looks to be  the same one Jess is wearing in this  Instagram shot she is taking some heat  from fans for wearing it but Jess didn't  seem bothered by the backlash she went  on to post this pic from the trip with  her girlfriends Stephanie Pearson and  Lauren Harrison not on the trip though  Jess and Eric's adorable tots  they left the kids at home for the  adults-only retreat